consideran los números un tercio siete y
quince a cuales los siguientes conjuntos
de números pertenecen y bueno aquí tengo
los números naturales los números
naturales unión en cero los números
enteros racionales irracionales y reales
y bueno sería bastante bueno que
recordaremos qué clase de conjuntos cada
uno así que vámonos por partes pensemos
primero en los números naturales los
números naturales son aquellos números
con los que podemos contar sin contar el
cero porque justo en el conjunto de
abajo lo vamos a agregar los números con
los que podemos contar y bueno podemos
contar con el 1 ok con el 2 ok con el 3
con el 4 y con todos los demás
cualquiera de estos números nos sirven
para poder contar ok
bueno aquí tengo los números naturales
son los números más fáciles y los
primeros que se encontraron ok pero si
ahora pensamos en los números naturales
unión el 0 que es nuestro siguiente
conjunto aquí me refiero
bueno pues ajustó los mismos números 1
34 180 etcétera y le vamos a unir le
vamos a pegar el 0 por lo tanto los
números naturales unión el 0 empezarían
en cero después tendremos el 1 el 2 el 3
el 4 y así sigue y sigue y sigue y es un
conjunto de números infinito al igual
que éste después pensemos en los números
enteros
los números enteros son todos los
números naturales el 0 y la versión
negativa de todos los números naturales
es decir si nosotros nos fijamos los
números enteros bueno pues empezaríamos
con un número muy pero muy pero muy
negativo así que voy a poner aquí
primero puntitos y después por ejemplo
llegaríamos al menos 5 menos 4 - 3 - 2 -
1 después pasaremos por el 0 por el 1
por el 2 por el 3 por el 4 y todos las
todos los demás si te das cuenta tenemos
aquí a todos los números naturales y
bueno su versión negativa ahora si
pensamos en los números racionales
estamos pensando en los números
que se pueden ver la siguiente manera
son todos los números de la forma m / n
donde m y n son enteros m y n enteros
es decir que un número racional son
todos los números que se pueden escribir
como una razón de dos enteros y bueno
nosotros podríamos pensar por ejemplo en
2 sept imos no sé en menos tres cuartos
podremos pensar también en 55 lo podemos
ver como cinco sobre uno o como dos a
uno espera o como veinte sobre cuatro o
como diez sobre dos todos estos
representan a la misma cantidad que
cinco entonces todos los números en
entonces todos los números enteros son
números racionales y bueno también
podemos contar con el 0 el cerdo podemos
ver como 0 sobre 1 o sea sobre 2 o lo
que sea no todos estos son números
racionales y ahora pensemos los números
irracionales los números irracionales
bueno son los que no son racionales es
decir los que no se pueden escribir como
una fracción como una relación entre dos
enteros o dicho de otra manera también
lo podemos ver como aquellos números que
tienen un punto decimal infinito y no
periódico pero bueno ya hablaré con más
calma de los números racionales en algún
vídeo especial sobre los profesionales
pero aquí depositar algunos por ejemplo
en los clásicos raíz de 2 ok a déjame
abrir este simbolito de conjuntos raíz
de dos pi pi es uno de los nuevos
irracionales más clásicos que hay en
etcétera
no hay una infinidad de números
irracionales y de hecho en uno de mis
próximos vídeos voy a probar justo eso
ok y los números reales bueno los
números reales vamos a simplificarlo
diciendo que son los números racionales
unión los números irracionales cuando yo
junto a estos dos obtengo los números
reales entonces voy a poner si los
números racionales racionales
unión unión los números irracionales y
si es de lujo ahora vamos a fijarnos en
estos tres valores que tengo aquí y
vamos a ver en cuántos y en qué
conjuntos de estos están en qué
conjuntos pertenecen así que cambiemos
de color y fijémonos en un tercio un
texto es el primero de estos números y
vamos a ver a qué conjuntos pertenece
así que déjame ponerlo aquí un tercio un
tercio pertenece y bueno si pensamos en
los números naturales los números
naturales no tienen que habrá dos no
tienen fracciones por lo tanto no puedo
decir que un tercio es un número natural
además los números naturales nos sirven
para contar y un tercio tendríamos que
contar algo dividido en partes por lo
tanto no creo que me sirva mucho en
números naturales unión en cero tampoco
tampoco no funciona porque aquí tengo a
los mismos y el cero pero un tensión al
cero por lo tanto no es un número
natural unión en cero números enteros
tampoco me sirve porque los números
enteros son los números naturales y
quedamos que un tercio no es un número
natural unión el cero aquí está el cero
pero un tercio nos el cero y su versión
negativa de todos
números naturales pero como un tercio no
es natural pues la versión negativa
tampoco va a ser un valor válido para un
tercio números racionales todos aquellos
números de la forma en mente en donde m
y n son enteros o perfecto este si
funciona si te das cuenta un tercio es
un número racional racional porque lo
podemos ver racional porque lo podemos
ver como la razón de dos números enteros
uno que es un número entero tres que es
un número entero por lo tanto un tercio
es un número racional ok y racional no
no no puede ser racional porque todo el
número que sea racional por definición
no es racional y viceversa de hecho son
contrarios estos dos pero en lo que sí
es sin duda es un número real es un
número real porque los reales unos
racionales unión los irracionales pero
como un tercio racional pues entonces es
real de lujo ahora vamos a ver nuestro
siguiente número en esta lista que es 7
pensemos en el siete el siete es un
número natural
claro es un número natural porque
podemos contar siete siete vacas siete
libros siete niños no se siete no sirve
para contar y por lo tanto su número
natural natural ok y si es natural pues
es natural unión el cero por lo tanto
también puedo decir que es un natural
natural
unión el 0 unión el 0 y el 0 ok y
también puedo decir que es un número
entero porque siete es un número natural
y los números enteros tienen a todos los
números naturales por lo tanto también
es un número entero es un número entero
ok y también podemos decir que es un
número racional podemos decir eso porque
habíamos dicho que todo el número entero
es racional o porque podemos ver a 7
como 7 sobre 1 14 sobre 2 qué sé yo por
lo tanto también es un número racional
racional ok y si es un número racional
no es racional pero lo que sí sabemos es
que es real es real y no es un nuevo
racional porque recuerda que no hay
ningún número irracional y racional al
mismo tiempo
ok pues ahora bajemos esto de aquí vamos
a bajar un poco esto para poner el
último que es menos 15 y lo voy a
escribir justo aquí menos 15 menos 15 am
qué tipo de número es bueno pues en
definitiva no es un número natural
porque es un número negativo los números
naturales siempre son positivos
no es un número natural de unión el cero
porque el menos 15 no es el 0 pero si
podemos decir que es un número entero el
menos 15 es un número entero porque es
la versión negativa de un número natural
que el número natural el 15 es decir que
cuando nos tomamos la versión negativa
del 15 llegamos al menos 15 y por lo
tanto es un número entero también es un
nuevo racional habíamos dicho que todos
los números enteros eran racionales
entonces lo voy a poner aquí racional y
es un número racional porque podemos ver
al menos 15 como menos kits sobre 11
menos 30 sobre 2 o cualquier otro ok
número irracional no no es irracional si
es racional no es racional pero si es
real si es real porque los reales tienen
a todos los racionales y como este
racional entonces está dentro de los
números reales y bueno ya cabe este
ejercicio así que nos vemos en el
siguiente